do you want me to sing my song to you
they wrote about how much I appreciate
you cleaning the house is it a real song
I thought you were kidding not a real
song let me hear your song you want to
hear it really yeah okay
Beth is the perfect wife she loves
Clorox and Lysol wipes life with Beth is
like a dream she protects me from covet
19 she cleans the germs the dust and
dirt in her half crop top belly shirt
she makes me safe in quarantine she's
like a sexy mr. clean as I sit here in
my room I hear the sweet sound of her
vacuum
my bath protects me
she dissing fax me she doesn't take it
personal when she scrubs my urine home
that's love for me
is built on trust and getting rid of all
the dust she's the other half that makes
me whole and she listens and cleans my
toilet bowl washes my boxers and my
socks
even cleans the litter box she's all
that keeps my or mine sane she even mops
up the cat pee stains she's there to
smile when I feel
and to wipe up my apple crisp
Metamucil cry
[Music]
my house was filled with dirt and grime
god that's a sourdough Beth cleaned it
all in her downtime
but cleans the house and keeps me laid
we're just like Arnold Schwarzenegger
and his maid we'll be together till the
end
that's not just my maid she's my best
friend yeah it moved yeah it's our life
but for the last three weeks you know
for me I'm living my fantasy I'm doing a
show a radio show from my basement and
then when I wasn't doing shows I would
dream like hey and one day maybe I'll
get laid some with the hottest woman
yeah I'm real high I'm with the
harnessed woman so you know it's not all
bad I don't know what your dream was bad
was it
was it being locked up with me honey
what was your dream cleaning a house no
I love you love you I love my song so
much thank you so much thank you